women in this world were lied to when
they were told you can have it all
there's no such thing there's always a
price to pay and there's always going to
be something has to give
so if you want the career and you want a
phd and you want to be a boss babe and
you want to have all of those things
it's your choice it's your life but just
be aware that there are women who came
before you who were told the same thing
and you can find them on tiktok crying
about the fact that it's not true
and they thought that at 35 and 38 they
would find a nice 38 year old man a 40
mi 40 year old man to marry them and
have a family and all of that kind of
thing because they still wanted that and
then they find that oh there's no men
because all the men married earlier or
they married younger than them and they
can still do that i don't want our
sisters to
to get fooled like they got fooled i
want us to to be smarter than that so
that we don't end up giving up something
that maybe was actually really important
to you
because you thought you could have it
all that's all i'm saying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special guest sister
naima salaam alaikum
so how is it going
all good masha'allah all good we're
grateful for every blessing
alhamdulillah all the way
so i've heard uh your tic-tac-famous now
apparently so yeah and after about 10
10-15 years online it's about time it's
about time it was coming
it was coming
yeah so the mob quote-unquote is coming
for you right
um i think there were
a couple of things that i said that
people didn't like
i think
maybe the things i said
the way that i said them
the language i used and the tone was
something that was unfamiliar to my
usual audience
and i'm going to be honest uh you know
at this point and say that i have
changed in certain
respects when it comes to the way that i
see
especially male female dynamics and that
i can't deny that if you watch some of
my videos from 2019 for example
i said things there that were you know
what my sisters needed to hear at the
time i felt and what i believed
but the thing is that a lot of the time
within the community we live in echo
chambers and we we we're in our own
bubble
so
you can be in a bubble of people who all
believe like you do see the world that
you do and they love what you're saying
you know
it fits in with what they want to see
how they want to see the world but the
problem is when you come out of that
bubble if you come out of that chamber
and you start to look at things from
another's point of view in this case for
me
starting to actually listen to men and
hear what men have to say about these
things what men's experiences are
you can't go back into that bubble again
you can't go back into that but you
can't unknow what you now know right
it's just like a brother who's grown up
talking to brothers his whole life he's
never really listens to sisters
once you know when men are together they
speak a certain way when sisters are
together women are together we talk a
particular way now if that brother is
privy to certain conversations where
women are being very honest very open
and telling their stories
he can't go back now to that brother's
space and talk the way that he used to
because he's seen the other side of it
and that's been my journey that's why
i'm here now speaking the way that i
speak and saying some of the things that
i say that are uncomfortable and that
are
are not what people want to hear but
it's the truth you know it's the reality
so
this is this is this is the interesting
thing so i see that certain people
obviously see that shift
it's an uncomfortable thing for them
it's it's actually a scary thing for
them some people say like i don't know
who you are anymore i feel like i can't
trust you anymore and i'm like says it's
okay
like
i've got a few more years in this dunya
than you and i've been through a bit
more than you and if i'm saying this
stuff to you and to my sisters it's
nothing more than i say to myself and my
friends
i'm not out here pointing fingers at
anybody i'm here looking in the mirror
from a place of honesty and
vulnerability and trying to be real and
keep it real and keep it 100. if you
don't like that
well
block and delete it's very easy unfollow
it's not a big deal
um
i think that's the issue with cancer
cultures today you say anything that
goes against mainstream media status quo
and you're automatically a villain
so what are some of these so-called
things that you're talking about that
you've you've heard the voices of men
you've begun to unplug i hate to use
that word but unplug from the the whole
matrix the whole gynocracy like what are
you noticing now what new things have
you
learned well i always knew um
instinctively that
we have our own lived realities every
single one of us does as individuals and
of course as men and women especially
especially in the muslim community we do
live in almost different worlds and then
on top of that our biology you know the
way we're acculturated the way that we
we've been brought up means that we have
differing viewpoints
i would say that coming from the space
that i've come from which is a very very
female space alhamdulillah obviously you
know all my friends are women i ran
sisters magazine for 10 years i've been
working with and supporting women for
the past 20 years so obviously it's a
very female space what happens in that
space is that you
start to believe women's versions of
everything
so the way that we see the world becomes
the truth
and because up until very recently i
would say
muslim men have not been speaking
we never heard the brother's side and i
don't mean muslim men have not been
talking no they've been talking because
the imam is a is male the scholars are
male the daughter male most tv
presenters are male so i'm not talking
about preaching islam i'm not talking
about you know men's kind of saying
things i'm talking about men
actually speaking about their own
experiences and their personal opinions
and their personal experiences
we haven't had spaces like that really
until very recently
and now you're seeing spaces where men
muslim and non-muslim are coming
together and speaking
their lived experience and when you well
like i said when you go into those
spaces and you hear those conversations
you start to see that hold on a minute
it's not just one victim here there
isn't
it's not always the sister who's the
victim and the brother who's the
perpetrator which is the version of the
world that many of us sisters do live in
right and maybe for brothers it's the
same
maybe brothers also think oh the sisters
are always like just you know making
noise about something and then we have
to suffer for whatever but again
us being stuck in those
polar positions
is damaging for us as individuals and i
believe it's damaging for us as a
community and so i'm really i'm glad to
be able to be in spaces where we as
brothers and sisters can actually
have honest respectful conversations
where
we all have the same goal at the end of
the day you know we're not about to have
a battle of the sexes within the ummah
it's not acceptable
because allah has already shown us that
we need each other okay our relationship
is a symbiotic relationship and we will
never succeed if either one of us is
failing and that's a fact we need each
other
so
anything that is kind of making us not
speak to each other or look at each
other
through a lens that is overwhelmingly
negative anything from either side that
needs to be combated it needs to be
dealt with and of course i'm sure we're
going to talk about red pill and
feminism later but it's interesting you
know that these conversations are not
happening within the muslim community
where you would think we wouldn't need
to have those conversations because
allah made everything clear but as i'm
sure we'll get into it as we get into it
it's not as black and white as that you
know our community is impacted by the
outside environment much more than we
like to admit
[Music]
uh unfortunately there has been this
huge dichotomy uh between
men and women and it's not something
that's inherently uh islamic at all it's
something that is inherently i would say
uh western it's this western
lifestyle that you know propagated this
feminism and then in turn propagated
this red pill movement and if you look
at the similarities between someone who
follows something like red pill and a
woman who follows something like
feminism a lot of the time it stems from
the same place that they went through
some kind of hurt they're looking for
some longing and protection and then
they go to this this movement that gives
them that sense of you know i'm being
heard listened to and empowered but
subhanallah it's really unfortunate that
they're just continuing that dichotomy
because red pills are men feminism's for
women and it's like there's there's no
benefit there so there's there's a lot
of
uh benefit alhamdulillah from having
these
uh intersex you know dialogues and
discussions so that people can hear the
other side um
recently we were talking about blowing
up a tick tock and all that and not for
the right reasons um according to you
know those people but uh that's
something i went through recently and uh
although a lot of the time i was a bit
like you know these people are taking it
way too far slander this that the other
um i did hear a lot of the sisters out
and that completely changed my
perspective on it as well i really
resonate what you're saying with you
know speaking to the opposite side and
seeing you know where they're coming
from because every everyone's you know
the good guy on their side respectively
yeah 100
yeah it's true
yeah so let's get into it what were some
of the things that you feel that you
talked about you discussed that a lot of
people were uncomfortable with
i would say the biggest deal was what i
said about
women who are past a certain age and
have had a certain relationship history
understanding
where they fit in as far as men are
concerned in general now let's be clear
okay
every one of us has
some baseline requirements and then we
have nice to haves okay we have
different personalities we want a
different personality in our partner we
want different versions of the
relationship you know if you ask every
single one of you to describe your
perfect relationship you're not all
going to say the same thing because you
all have your home individual
personality right however
the important thing and one of the
things i would like to stress is
in general
we like to be told things that make us
feel good
okay
and
if i say to a sister and i and i say
this to my friends and i have said this
to myself
i am not 22.
i am not a 22 year old fresh graduate
never had a child never done any any of
that living
anymore
i'm not
it's okay
all right i'm in my 40s
rav
don't think that i you know that i am
what
people who would like to start a family
okay would like to start from scratch
with a wife who's going to grow with
them and and have his children they have
children together and they build their
life like i was when i first got married
okay i'm not that woman anymore that's a
reality it's okay to accept reality i
said to a friend of mine
you see
we are in the same position now as
muslim women as non-muslim women are
when they get to a certain stage in life
and they want to get married the
difference is a lot of us have already
been married whereas they maybe had like
a whole phase and all that kind of thing
we didn't do that but many of us i have
plenty of sisters who are like around my
age a little bit younger who uh you know
may have had a marriage or two
have had children they would like to
find someone okay but now they're in
their late 30s 40s divorced a couple of
times don't really want to have any more
children physically
at the end of the day late 30s early 40s
you're you're on your you know your your
peak of fertility is gone okay maybe
even your peak of health might be gone
if you haven't looked after yourself
very well not only that
but emotionally
and mentally you are not the same
if you've been through a divorce or two
you have been through some kind of
trauma a lot of the time okay even if it
was an amicable divorce guys just just
because it's an amicable divorce does
not mean that there is not pain that you
may have resolved or you may not have
resolved and that's why you find a lot
of sisters who kind of come out of this
situation and they're in that space of
life their list is really long
because they know they don't want this
they don't want that anymore they're not
going to do this again they're not
having that they're not doing this
they're not having that they're not
doing this not only are they not doing
this but they also now want uh he has to
support me financially he needs to be
you know i need to be sexually attracted
to him uh you know he needs to have good
dean i wanted to be a step dad to my
kids and a father figure um and and then
whatever race maybe uh physical
attributes maybe he needs to like
reading he needs to like going on long
walks
all this stuff right
my message is sis
the pool is smaller where we are
okay
we have to be realistic it's not a fairy
tale in fact one of the tick tocks was
making fun of the fact that i said it's
not a fairy tale cyst
it's not a fairy tale
if you want fairy tales
netflix and chill by yourself
because that's where the fairy tales are
okay in the songs in the movies in the
tv that's the fairy tale that there's
some perfect guy out there
waiting for it to scoop up your 35 old
behind and your three children he's the
ideal guy is there somewhere i'm like
says rude who said that
who promised you an ideal man did allah
say that
does and in fact the sister said
actually
they've left a message on my instagram
and she said
older and divorced women deserve the
same rights as xyz and i thought that
was so interesting
because who is to say who deserves what
can any of us say we deserve
anything more than i think fair
treatment may be you know a decent
person but can you say you deserve xyz
or is it allah who gives and takes i
don't get it but anyway
the thing that i said was
sometimes you may and the thing is there
are lots of things that make a partner
more desirable or less desirable in the
market place which is another thing that
i got slated for using the word
marketplace as if we're objects to be
bought and sold so you've got issues sis
you've got issues if you hear me use the
word marketplace and you feel
objectified i'm sorry but i'm not taking
that i'm not going to carry the burden
of your understanding of my language
have you not been on muzz match before
you're not seeing how those things work
swipe left and swipe right that's not a
marketplace to you that's not amazon.com
to you
of course it is because all we're doing
is literally judging a book by its cover
more times than not
and looking for certain maybe red flags
or certain things that oh he's working
what's the job accountant okay yeah i'll
swipe right so that's that's shopping
that's what you guys are doing at the
end of the day when we nowadays this
this again guys
i'm going to be calm
it's not ideal
it's not ideal
but it is what it is
and the sooner you understand what it is
the sooner you can start winning in the
space of what is real
versus what is ideal because the ideal
doesn't exist especially not for people
you know we've talked to you know
brothers i was a sister was saying a
sister who's older maybe she's older
she'd be married or whatever these
things that men seem to consider
important somehow
i'm not sure why that is many people are
upset about the fact that men care that
they're older or that men care that
they've been divorced why should you
care oh i feel like that shouldn't
matter but it's not for us to feel like
it shouldn't matter that's not our
business
because again i'm going to use market
language
there's a supply and there's a demand
yes or no
yeah it's a buyer's market too it's not
romantic guys it's not hollywood it's
not disney it's not much
it's literally people making choices
about who they are going to invest their
time and their effort and resources in
and you know doing it for reasons that
they hope are the right reasons okay so
going back to what i was saying
you know you've got this this this
marketplace and um
you know where people are kind of making
these choices and trying to find
somebody
most of the time people are not falling
in love at first sight
it's not your magnetic personality okay
it's not your kindness it's not your
generosity that is going to pull that
person to you because of the way that we
even finding each other is it ideal no
because in an ideal world we would
hardly see the outside things we would
see directly to the heart
is this person a good person do they
have iman are they kind are they
generous do they care about others are
they committed these things these
matters of character of the heart in an
ideal world that's all we would care
about in an ideal world would be able to
see those things straight away
do we live in an ideal world no we do
not
we live in a world where we have lots of
other things that you know that we are
you know trying to take into account and
also things that we're using to make
choices so what i wanted to say was
men
many men i said all men but many men
have certain preferences for their woman
a woman that they want to start a family
with
sis it's not for us to say whether those
preferences are correct or not
it's not because at the end of the day
you're not the one choosing he's the one
who's looking for what he wants so you
can't shame him into not wanting that i
don't think that that's fair because we
sisters don't get shamed per se for what
we want even though sometimes what we
want is way like
beyond what is even reasonable which is
in line with women in general yeah this
is not a muslim woman saying this is
women in general women in general are
the ones who have those long long long
lists and all the different things that
disqualify someone from dating et cetera
there's just women in general but my
point is this
just as
we you know if a brother has got no
money
and has no prospects
no one cares about his heart
no one cares about his character really
a lot of the time it's like oh you're
not gonna provide for me okay halas
you know and and even for for you know a
brother there could be many things money
could be one of them he could be
aesthetically
not top of the range he could be
overweight he could have a disability he
could be living with his parents and not
intending to move all of these things
make him less desirable right yes or no
according to what sisters are generally
looking for so it's okay to acknowledge
that there are preferences at play now
your decision is am i going to pay
attention to the preferences am i going
to
prioritize me finding a spouse or am i
going to prioritize my list
and no one's shaming you either way if
you want your list keep your list but
understand that it may stop you from
achieving your objective if it is to
find a spouse and if your objective is
to find a spouse you may want to look at
that list with a more critical eye and
ask yourself do i qualify for this
person this perfect person because just
like people said another thing that
people didn't like is that i said that
people should be realistic they said i'm
telling sisters to settle
let me tell you something
any one of us chooses any one of us
we're going to be settling
why because it's very rare to find
someone who fits everything on your list
that is a fact and the more traits you
have that make you less desirable the
more that brother is settling for you
do you think that we say he marries you
he's happy to marry you masha'allah he
likes you you know he's attracted to you
thinks you're a good person and he's
ready to commit to you but you have five
children
don't you think that there was a thought
process in his head to say you know what
it would have been better if she didn't
have five kids but alhamdulillah is
worth it yes or no
but but we never say that the brother is
settling
because settling is something women do
and women should have to settle okay
don't settle do you think you're all
that stay be bad and stay like that
because that attitude even the attitude
of i won't settle i deserve the best i
deserve this and this and this it's an
entitled attitude that has no basis
and i would rather that sisters have
again sorry to go on about this but i
think sisters heard something that i
didn't say
in that your value to a husband is
somehow indicative of your value as a
person and that is not true
because every single one of us has
intrinsic value as a human being and to
allah every single one of us has value
no matter your age your race your you
know marital history physically whatever
allah looks at our hearts he looks at
our man that is never in question but
when you're looking to get married your
value it's not about your value as a
human being it's not about how valuable
you are to allah it is how valuable you
are to this man or this woman and that
is their perception
that will determine how valuable you are
so someone will choose you in spite of
certain things that they don't like
because they consider you to be of value
enough value for them to invest in you
this is male and female it's okay for us
to acknowledge these realities i think
it's it's an ideal versus real type of
uh conversation i think that's what i
feel is happening here yeah ladies i
think sister naima is basically saying
the same thing that i've said but
you know after after getting canceled
all these times when i keep saying high
value man or woman i'm not talking about
in the eyes of allah i'm talking about
in the marketplace hate to use these
terms but i'm saying it as it is right
this isn't you know and then we talk
about education should women chase
careers and all this
and they're like oh what do you mean the
all this hobby they were educated they
knew the dean i ain't talking about that
i'm talking about these useless
anthropology degrees and stuff like that
but i don't hate on anthropology degrees
i wanted to take an anthropology degree
anthropology's lit man what but the
point is you're right it's it's if you
want to take an anthropology degree it's
fadi but don't think that it makes you
more valuable as a wife and mother
because that's not necessarily the case
again it's the value isn't it so maybe
if you go for a job as a university
lecturer your anthropology degree counts
maybe if you're speaking to a brother
who wants to start a family your
anthropology degree may not count or it
may even be a step down because he's
thinking uh is she going to be happy
with being at home that's i want you
know do you understand like
and this is the other thing as well and
i think i mentioned this on a different
conversation is that we as women
this generation and the one that's
coming up and the one that's coming up
afterwards
we've been taught to value certain
things about us which you could say are
have traditionally been masculine
pursuits okay success academically
success in the workplace money okay
property uh you know the coin okay
traditionally very masculine concerns
very masculine pursuits traditionally
again no shame
i have a business of my own
whatever it is what it is but the point
is
we value those things about ourselves
we're proud of those things society has
taught us to be proud of them and we've
put in a lot of work we've put in a lot
of time and effort and resources etc
into becoming that person
so
it's almost a slap in the face
when you speak to somebody for the
potential prospect of marriage
he doesn't rate it like that
he's not impressed he's not impressed he
wants to know can you cook though
can you clean
and the real the real sting
is that we look down on cooking and
cleaning and raising children because
we've been fed on the feminist kool-aid
and i'm gonna say it guys and i'm gonna
say it because i felt it myself i'm not
here pointing fingers like i said i'm
here looking in the mirror
but i've had those situations where
somebody has you know been considering
me for marriage
and i tell them what i do
and their response is but how does that
affect you
in the home
i tell you i got triggered so bad
i was triggered because i was like
what you mean like you're supposed to be
impressed by what i do you're supposed
to think this this is an amazing woman
yeah i definitely want to be on her
program no
that's not what he's looking for
he is thinking to himself okay this is
cool mashallah nice but does that mean
that i'm going to now have less of her
does it mean that she's going to want to
argue with me does it mean that we're
going to be fighting for like who leads
and you know who understands more and
whose decision gets to understand that's
what he's thinking it's unfortunate
ladies
but i do believe it's the truth brothers
you're all here please tell me that i'm
talking utter nonsense if i'm talking
utter nonsense but this has been my
experience yeah yeah just to um just to
give my own perspective on that as as a
muslim man i believe personally what a
woman makes is completely
inconsequential and the reason i say
that is because as a man i'm obligated
to to provide so whether she makes money
or not doesn't matter because she's not
going to be spending like my wife's
money is her money and like it doesn't
matter so whether she has this not the
other it doesn't matter but what i
personally
find um
uh well frankly attractive is motherhood
a woman
and i say this is going to be a good
mother
maybe it's
something
as men that's something that i'm 100
inclined towards
bro i agree with that but women
psychologically can't turn off that ceo
muscle and turn on housewife muscle it
just it doesn't work in the real world
that's just my personal objective or
subjective findings yeah
it's something that she definitely wants
to do
but she needs to want to do it i think i
would say it's not impossible but she
needs to want to do that because we can
always change as human beings i believe
that you know this this is something we
can control and if a woman wants to
change she can it's been done many many
times before however
you can't turn a ceo into a housewife
against her will that's not gonna happen
because it's and again i want to i want
to just just
make this point again because i want the
sisters in the back to hear it
when
if and when
a man asks you about cooking or cleaning
or looking after the home or your vision
for your family and your children okay
the wife role the mother role
if you feel in any way
insulted by that or you feel it's a red
flag or you feel that you know he's kind
of downgrading you
check yourself
because that is definitely part of the
programming
feminism did what it did but it did not
do whatever it did for femininity if
anything it encouraged us to be
masculine and which is crazy because
that assumes that masculinity is the
model masculinity is the superior model
and women should be allowed to be
masculine like that of course men are
not allowed to be masculine anymore we
don't want that because that's toxic
can't have that
but women yes boss girl all of all of
that stuff that you see out there that
unfortunately some of our young women
are also jumping on the bandwagon of
see it for what it is allah has
described our roles very clearly guys
like there is no you may talk about red
pill whatever i remember somebody saying
that islam is red pilled i said
if you compare islam to what so-called
red pill manosphere trad cons etc see as
the traditional roles islam is that
because it's traditional
islam is inherently traditional when it
comes to gender roles that may sting
you may hate to hear it but it's true
are those roles rigid are they as
oppressive as we've seen no
the seerah shows us that but in general
the gender roles that islam that we've
been taught in islam are the traditional
roles that you see in almost every
single society throughout the history of
the world and through everywhere right
so again if you feel that being a mother
or a wife is a downgrade
to check yourself because it could be
that there is something in your heart
there that is not at ease with being a
woman in the way that allah
said or is not at ease with your
femininity and that you're fighting with
this this idea or this notion and which
means you probably don't really want to
be a wife in the traditional sense i
think some women talk about wanting to
get married not because they want to be
someone's wife but because they want
company you know they want a companion
they don't want to be lonely anymore
it's not quite the same as being a wife
i'm afraid you know a wife has a job
just like a husband has a job someone is
your man you might not necessarily be
your husband because a husband has
certain responsibilities similarly a
wife has certain responsibilities and if
we're not prepared
to take on those responsibilities then
we have to really ask ourselves you know
am i actually wife material
like no cat
am i wife material if you look in the
mirror and you say would i marry me
not would i hook up with me not would i
like me not would i have a thing for me
no would i marry me would i commit to
myself would i cleave to myself and pour
my resources my time my energy my seed
into me
and entrust all of that in me
can i do that
am i up to the task what does it even
mean to be a wife anyway is it basically
me i just show up
and i'm the halal whatever is that what
being a wife is because unfortunately
from what i'm hearing and again this is
anecdotal but the word on the street is
if you do press sisters to say what do
you bring to the table
we've got sisters out here saying i
don't cook
i don't like cooking i don't like
cleaning i've got debts um you know i my
kids like i'm kind of struggling with
them whatever uh you know i don't really
want to live with someone or i don't
want you to come into my house or i
don't want to move into your house and
you know and i'm working on my this and
i'm working on my that and you know at
the end of the day when you bring in you
boil it all the way down you've got some
sisters who really when you ask them
okay okay okay stop capping now what do
you bring to the table she'll be like
well it's a halal thing in it
and it's like
that's not a wife
halal ting is not a wife
a wife is there's a job description
do you qualify for that job description
are you prepared
to do the job
if you're not prepared to do the job get
honest with yourself and make a decision
you either want the job or you don't if
you want the job
start acting like it start talking like
it and start preparing for it otherwise
you don't have anything to complain
about because asthma is not really what
you want you say you want to be a wife
but in your heart it's like i don't want
to do that
no i want to go for romantic dinners and
brunches that's what i want to do
i want the cool stuff that's what i want
i want to hear what ann has to say about
that because just like yourself angela
is also a revert he reverted about a
year ago so
i want to hear if uh what you're what
you hear right now it aligns with what
you've felt most of your life but also
what you're learning now about muslim
women
say bismillah bro what are you doing
well it's in my head man it's the whole
like i think there's another thing too
it's it's the perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so i'm going to bless you for that first
of all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zortsis we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
yeah yeah it does and i want to say this
is the breast breath of fresh air this
is like a one out of ten type woman
who's gonna say these things i'm just
being honest with you not trying to hype
you up not trying to criticize you or
anything we don't do the pedestals
remember you're gonna do better
listen we don't do that
but um i wanna touch on two points
all right so number one when you were
talking about
women getting
degrees and then having businesses and
stuff like that and thinking that that
adds inherent value to them as a woman
as a candidate to be a wife
i think it depends right that's a loaded
question in the sense where it's like
ask them why they're doing it
like why did they get that degree why
are they in that profession why do they
have this business if the if the answer
is because they needed to
basically provide for themselves or make
money all right it doesn't add any value
but if a woman tells me like oh i'm very
passionate
about
designing or about um
i don't know hello you understand what
i'm saying if she's passionate about
this thing and it's not about the money
but there's real passion there to where
she's doing
good work and it's
it's like it's almost feminine you know
like when i see that i was like that's
very feminine you know she's not worried
too much about providing for herself
she's just worried about like
okay am i doing something good like am i
my passion is there emotion here is
is there you know you you get it's a
passion you know so i guess it's a
loaded question and
it depends
right yeah it depends for a man if
they're
if they're looking and then like me
personally that's that's how i see it
and for the other thing when you said
for a woman to ask yourself the question
it could be the same for a man
ask themselves the question
am i
spouse material like would i
be with myself for this this and that um
and and all would i trust myself what
all this stuff right
again that's a loaded question because
think about how egotistical everyone is
like come on we look at ourselves in the
mirror and we're just looking we're like
ooh
masha'allah
not everyone though unfortunately some
of us look in the mirror and we just
shake our heads and we're like oh no
no no
it's true oh no i'm not feeling himself
right there listen listen listen i'm not
trying to get to that i'm i'm saying
that like
whether it's our appearance whether it's
our behavior whether it's our
personality whether it's our profession
the amount of money we're bringing in
something that we always
try to see ourselves like even if we are
our own worst critic
we also
are the person who sees ourselves in the
best light
so with that question it's more so like
the person has to really
humble themselves
and just ask like the genuine
question and really just respond
authentically as authentically as
possible in order to see okay am i am i
actually a proper candidate
or am i just trying to fool myself
i love that you mentioned humble because
this is this is an interesting dichotomy
because the sister messaged me and she
said like how dare you tell sisters of a
certain bracket that they should you
know kind of be realistic with their
expectations don't you know sisters
already have low self-esteem and are
already like settling for less than they
deserve okay and i want to speak to that
because
as we're having these conversations we
have to understand that the human
experience is so multifaceted and there
is no way we can ever say muslim men
this muslim women that uh you know
virgins single mothers divorcees xyz we
can't do that because everyone's
experience is different however
to your point about being humble um when
i did my video about you know single
single muslim women do you really need a
man right
um
the big thrust of that video was
speaking to
that woman who maybe has been through a
marriage it didn't work she would like
to find love again she wants to have a
family because hey being a single parent
period you're not just mom but being a
single parent is tough okay so she's
lonely she's stretched she's all these
things and she's looking for somebody
online or wherever the case may be and
my thing was and it still is
do the work on yourself first before you
go out there
because there are no saviors out there i
don't believe there are people who are
equipped to save us from ourselves if my
life is a mess
and i'm on line swiping left and right
trying to find someone to come and fix
it and sweep it up for me i am going to
fall victim to people who feed on my
insecurity who feed on my weakness on my
low self-esteem and my you know my sense
of unworthiness
that's not what i want for anyone man or
woman
so every one of us has the
responsibility to get ourselves in order
first again it's that conversation in
the mirror right where you're saying you
know would i with myself would i commit
to myself would i invest in myself and
be honest and if the answer is no
understand that you have the wherewithal
to fix it yourself
allah put you in this situation he can
get you through it but sometimes you'll
have to find strength from places that
you didn't know before and i and i will
still say
that we don't preach
emotional resilience and self-reliance
enough to sisters
when you hear people talking on the
pulpit or the member
they often will talk about sisters who
are vulnerable divorcees widows uh you
know whatever whatever the case may be
and they'll say it's for the men of the
community to stand up i remember when i
was in nigeria there was a q and a
session after one of the big conferences
mufti bank was there and some other
people and i was the only speaker only
female speaker but they had me on stage
as well and someone asked the question
about i think it was widows or single
mothers right because there's a lot of
divorce happening everywhere right and
most of the time the children end up
staying with the mother except in some
instances where the father sends the
mother the wife away and he keeps the
kids anyway
when they answered the question
initially they brought the theory
the theory is what the theory is that no
woman left behind right
the theory is no sister left behind
because she has a mahram she has a
father she has an uncle she has a
brother she should have men in the
community who are prepared to look after
her and make sure that she doesn't
struggle make sure that she doesn't have
to fend for herself
this is the theory
it's the ideal
but again i ask is that the reality
it's not the reality and that was when i
spoke up i said this sounds really good
but that's not what's happening on the
ground what's happening on the ground is
that women are being left with the
responsibility of these children many
fathers no longer involved after the
divorce there is no village there is no
community okay people who are stretched
and struggling especially in the west
you don't have your father paying your
bills who does that who has you know if
if her husband is no longer there whose
father is stepping in and saying you
know come home
come home with the children you know
where they'll be raised with the
grandfather and the grandmother who does
that you know the brother is he going to
give you a monthly stipend from his
salary his wife's going to have a
problem with that because she's like why
doesn't she have a husband like you know
why doesn't she sort herself out so my
point is this is
the reality for me this is just my
opinion may allah forgive me if i'm
wrong but
telling those women who are in a
vulnerable situation that they need to
be even more reliant on a man from
somewhere
means that when they go into the dating
marketplace they are vulnerable because
they
their lives are in a mess
and they don't believe they can sort it
out unless there is a man but let me
tell you one thing when that man comes
in you've got another set of problems
sis because he didn't come in to save
you he came in to get his knees taken
care of no i'm sorry there's
i'm not i'm not
i don't demonize either we're all just
human beings at the end of the day but i
remember one sister
and we were having a gathering for
reverts and she was talking about you
know this pressure on reverts to get
married quite quickly especially revert
women to marry someone quickly so that
they can be absorbed into the muslim
family and and and you know hopefully
become more established in her islam
right
and
i said and this particular sister had a
lot of like mental issues and she was
very lonely and she was really
struggling and everything and i said to
her sis
my advice to you
is learn your deen
strengthen your iman
and get happy
then look for a husband
because guess what
most men
are not therapists
most men are not counselors
most men do not have the tool kit needed
to sort you and your mental emotional
and spiritual and physical state out and
putting that on him is unfair
especially someone you met from online
and that's why a lot of brothers i i
noticed that brothers who have been
looking for a while they become jaded
because they're like every sister's got
a sob story every sister that i've
spoken to or she's talking about is the
brother that did her wrong and this one
who left her and this one who did that
i'm sorry sis i'm so sorry and i'm
saying this while allah knows from a
place of love if that is your
relationship history you have to heal
you can't be out here speaking to a
potential partner and basically reeling
off a disastrous history of abuse and
toxicity and wounding and attachment and
dinner all of these things because who
wants to sign up for that and the one
who does want to sign up for that even
for me is more of a red flag
because as a man why are you doing that
like no no no no because if you told
your friends yeah bro like you know
she's got depression and you know she's
been divorced three times and she's got
you know four baby daddies
but yeah i'm thinking it could be good
still it's like uh no no no no you
you've got you've seen something else
here you know there's there's a
vulnerability that you've tapped into
for whatever weird reason you think yeah
i can get what i need out of this
it's not a healthy place to be and that
is my thing is that let's get healthy
see this this begs a really important
question to me because i know you have
sons right so
i wonder what type of game do you put
your sons on what do you teach them but
before that i had a question related to
something before so i don't want to
forget so i'll ask this one first
feminism has led to a lot of women today
unsubscribing from this whole idea of
wanting to have kids okay
i really don't care non-muslim women do
you but this is bleeding into the umma
now this is bleeding into the identities
of muslim women who are now by and large
not most of them but this number is ever
increasing every day that they're turned
off from the idea of wanting to have
kids
where do you think this is stemming from
it's exactly as you said and it's
exactly what i said about if if somebody
asking you about how you would perform
the role of the traditional role of a
wife and mother if that makes you feel
some kind of way you need to examine
that because that is not coming from
fitra it's not coming from dean is
coming from somewhere else and i think
it's coming from the the the general
environment that we live in you know you
could say the gynocentric social order
you can say feminism you can say
whatever it is end of days right but it
is definitely something that we're being
programmed you know we're being
programmed these kids are being
programmed all the time and you know
subhanallah i'm a gen
gen x
so you know we grew up without the
internet obviously we only had
smartphones quite late into even our you
know those when we had our children and
everything
you guys millennials you know zinios are
they calling them gen z's
the amount of
the susceptibility to the programming
is like
times a hundred now
we had
leave it to beaver on tv
right we had uh my two dads on tv which
was bad enough because i grew up in
africa right so when we would watch
these american sitcoms and the kids
would be saying shut up to each other
this was like a cult it was like a
culture shock for us because it's like
like how that you know you know when the
kid would like back chatting the parents
or they would you know shout at the
parents saying that's not my fault mom
whatever for us that was a culture shock
it was like how are these kids getting
like what's happening right because that
was not our reality fast forward to
today that was tv programs once two
three times a week and that was all that
was available except for movies
now
we've got kids on tick tock on instagram
on everything all the time
constantly 24 7 whenever they want to
access it it's there and it's not just
you know shut up you idiot like it was
when i was young it is it's it's
everything out there so again
checking ourselves because what we know
is
the way to succeed is to be on the
serato
if you want the best of the dunya and
the without sacrificing your deen
you have to know what that looks like
you have to understand what it is that
you were created for why did allah put
me on this earth according to him
not according to what i think what i
feel
what feels good to me oh this is my
truth oh this is this is this is who i
am or this you know all of this stuff i
remember
there was a conference for rivert
and i think it was around the time when
a lot of famous hijabi uh like
influencers were taking off the hijabs
right and then they're making these
videos without hijab and they're saying
oh i realized that i wasn't being true
to myself and you know i you know i had
to i had to be true to myself and you
know you guys have always been honest
with you you know all that stuff
and i said you know what
you know who's loving this
shaitaan is loving this
because the people have been fooled into
making their nufs their guide
my truth
this is me this is how i feel what is
where does feeling come from where do
your desires come from desires are from
nafs and what have we been taught about
the nafs
the tough enoughs is not a a trustworthy
guide the nufs if you don't control it
and discipline it the enoughs is what
leads you astray so we're in a society
now where literally nufs is god
if you feel it feels good to you
it's all good
if you feel that it's your truth it's
all good but that's enough
so we need to be questioning ourselves
to say this path that i'm on how close
is it to the surat mustafi and is it
like going the complete opposite
direction because if i want to this
dunya is is this dunya is a trial but
it's also a beautiful place i'm sorry
guys i don't care what anyone says
my belief that i hold this dunya has
good and evil just like there's
opposites in everything there is so much
joy here to be had so much love so much
connection so much purpose here on this
earth for us to earn allah's pleasure
right
but you can enjoy it without sacrificing
your akhira allah did not put us in a
deen that means that you have no joy no
love no laughter no connection you know
none of the pleasures of the world are
for you if you want gender that's not
true
it's not true
the handful of things that are haram are
bad for us they're harmful they hurt us
and they hurt other people but aside
from the handful of things that's haram
the dunya is wide and vast
but we're not seeing it what we're
seeing is that handful of things that
are haram and we're seeing all the joy
and the love and the connection and the
fun it's all there that's what i want i
want the handful of haram i don't care
about all the other halal things i want
this haram here
subhanallah
[Music]
and subhanallah that we live in a time
where
men we can't even politely remind women
or sisters about hijab
like it's toxic
that's a tough one that's a tough one
because society is telling us you can't
tell women how to dress but
society is also moving sauce so you know
people just got to realize it
yeah
yeah it's a tough one and i think it's
it's helpful to remember
that the trajectory the cultural and
social trajectory of muslim women
is not like the socio-cultural
trajection of non-muslim western women
the the
non-muslim
non-muslim western women have been on
this path since the 60s okay
we can argue that sisters within the
muslim community have only been on this
path for like the last 20 years right
it's nothing like western women so we've
just come out of a space where women had
absolutely no voice
where a panel like this would be
impossible okay it would not be possible
for me to speak like this with you and
that's facts okay we just came out
literally the early 2000s a time when
sisters had no public voice no space to
speak about their issues at all
and a lot of sisters would have been
coming out of families where they saw
the way that their mothers did the whole
traditional role thing and they saw the
impact it had and they saw this
patriarchal norms and they've literally
fresh come out of that
they're not buying it
western women now are like we want to go
back to traditional roles a lot of asian
women are like excuse me we just came
out of that
we're not going back to that so my
hypothesis
because i just came out of the 90s and
the early 2000s as well i remember a
time okay where the brothers were the
masculine role models and like the
gender roles were you know strictly
defined and there wasn't any of this
kalam you're talking about not wanting
children and stuff like that there was
nothing like that
i remember what that was like
and that's why i say
we need to stop looking to the recent
past
we need to stop looking even to the not
so recent past what we need to be doing
is taking our guidance from the seerah
and looking forward to say how can we do
this in a healthy way
because just because you're a masculine
man doesn't mean you are a good person
just because you are a feminine woman
does not mean that you have good
character okay so just because people
are one is out to work and the other is
at home does not mean there is love
between them does not mean that they are
fully healed from whatever traumas they
had does not mean that they can
communicate doesn't mean that there is
you know the things that make a happy
home so the gender roles that allah has
laid out yes we need to reclaim those
but
we equally need to reclaim our own
spiritual emotional and mental health
so that we can be healthy individuals in
healthy relationships raising healthy
families because the gender roles make
no difference if you are a dysfunctional
human being that's that's facts
there we go that was that was just
straight facts i don't know how to leave
his internet does that every now and
then and then he comes back
but yeah uh if rami if you don't have
any questions i wanted to go on to my
next question about the suns
yeah go for it bro
i know bro good
my bad about that i was like wondering
in my head like yo i wonder what time it
is and then the
the stream guard just completely like
shut up
[Music]
yeah so
how are you raising your sons in this
time of mass fitna
subhanallah you know
having kind of paid attention to the
experiences of men and what men
talk about amongst themselves and in
particular the way that being raised by
a single woman impacted them
it humbles you you know it's humbling i
think that is one of the things that is
so difficult maybe for many sisters or
women in general to to to face is this
this humbling notion that
things are not the way you always
thought they were you know things are
not as black and white as you thought
you're not always the good guy sometimes
you're actually the bad guy sometimes
you are the problem sometimes you
yourself as a woman are the originator
of the problem and that's not something
that i had necessarily considered and i
don't think as women we're really
encouraged to see
what is happening with me
that is leading to the outcomes that i'm
seeing it's very easy to blame other
people because i'm just a woman right
and everybody else is responsible for me
it's always somebody else's fault
um
and anybody who takes issue with this
y'all know i'd be talking about you know
taking responsibility for yourself and i
have been talking about that ever since
ever so this is not a new thing but what
i will say is that i am acutely aware
of the fact that you know now my
children's father passed away
there are certain things that i can't
teach them
okay because i am not a man and i'm i'm
a woman i'm their mother you know
mothers have certain
sensibilities we have certain tendencies
we are the ones who tend to cuddle we're
the ones who tend to make excuses for we
because we want to protect that's our
nurturing instinct right um and that's
why the having the the father and the
mother in the home is so important
because they balance each other out
inshallah where the mother would make
excuses and kind of you know like let it
you know let it lie and say don't worry
whatever and you know just kind of make
it okay the father will take him to
account the father will pull him up on
it the father will discipline him right
again generalizations but anyway
in answer to your question i'm acutely
aware of the fact that my children by
and large have grown up without their
father and so them learning to be men in
this space is something that it's almost
a journey they will have to go on on
their own but what i will say is i will
i speak to them about how their father
was as a husband
uh how their father was as a father um
as the leader of the household you know
what he instilled in us and what he
created for us i need them to know that
so they know that they have some kind of
model you know they have they have a
legacy okay so that's one thing but i
think of late the main thing that i've
been saying to them is no simping to be
honest of course we talk to them about
you know staying chaste and respecting
themselves and not putting themselves in
haram situations and everything that the
dean teaches but aside from what the
dean teaches my boys know my rule is no
simping whatsoever
now what does no simping mean
for me my definition of simping is when
you invest time energy and resources in
a woman who does not appreciate you or
those those resources those things that
you're bringing yeah
uh so typically what i tell my boys i
said look
work on yourself
establish yourself as the best version
of yourself because at that point you
will be able to then choose your life
partner from a place of strength okay um
i want you to have your dean on point
your money on point you know your
education your career your vision on
point because at that stage in sha allah
you can pick who it is that you want
that fits in with your life vision the
other thing that i said to them is that
choose a woman who chooses you
not a woman that you have to convince to
get onto your program
this whole chasing and convincing and
like negotiating you know the whole
negotiated desire thing it's the other
thing with muslims and marriage is not
so much a desire thing because you can
desire someone and still not commit to
them in marriage you know what i mean
it's like it's not all about desire for
us but
i hope and inshallah i pray that allah
gives them a woman
who considers herself blessed to be with
him
she sees that man and she's like
yes
you know alhamdulillah like i i this is
he she is for you
you know she she rates you like that
it's so important because if you've got
a woman who's
meh
she could take it or leave it it's like
yeah okay if you do this this this this
this this this then maybe i'll consider
i'm gonna get red pill with y'all and
tell you move on
that's not the one for you
any woman who is making you jump through
hoops and hoops and hoops in order for
her to commit to you guess what after
you win her that's going to be your life
convincing her jumping through hoops on
her program going according to what she
wants basically pandering to her and
catering and keeping on that pedestal
because the minute that you don't like
the minute you bring her down from that
pedestal or you don't keep the pedestal
high enough she's going to call you out
and say but you used to do this and you
used to do that and now i'm not happy
and da da da
so
it sounds really kind of mean
but that is the advice i give to my sons
and one of the reasons why i can't take
a woman's side all the time is because i
have sons
i don't want my sons marrying some
entitled sister who doesn't want to
commit to them and is not like all in
you know she's not especially i'm
talking about young people here now
forget about the the second third
marriage people i'm talking about your
first marriage
for me my experience and what i've seen
and what i've learned the best way to
start off life is with somebody who is
that she's on your team you know so for
my sons i want you to marry somebody
who's on your team she's got your back
she's right or die
you don't have to have everything
figured out at the beginning but she has
to see the potential in you and be like
i'm i'm here for this program you know
and with my daughter i say the same
thing i said if there was a brother who
came for you
and i said what do you think of him and
you said oh well he's okay well i guess
if he does this this this and if he has
this this this then maybe i'll consider
him i'll say brother this is this she's
not the one for you sorry
it's not worth it
because that's going to be your life and
if that's your life that in my opinion
and from what i've read and what i've
seen
is not the stability that you want for
your family
the man has to have frame and he has to
maintain frame
and his wife if we're talking
traditional here his wife needs to be in
his frame she needs to be on his program
they could have discussed the program
and have come to the realization that
we're on the same program i love it i i
fully buy into this no problem
could be a co-created program it could
be it was his idea and then she liked it
and she hopped on i don't mind but you
have to be on the amir's program
otherwise he can't be the emir otherwise
there's two amir's in the house
you my dear friend have got your program
and you
have got your program and you're
constantly at loggerheads about who is
winning who is going to dominate the
other one again going back to stability
that's not the way for a stable marriage
and that's why we talk about the man
having kawam the man providing and
protecting and leading right
ideally ideally the woman trusts him
she trusts him to lead
it's this if you want a traditional
marriage you have to choose someone that
you can trust to lead
he may not get it right all the time he
probably won't get it right all the time
but that's who you chose that's who you
signed up for your role is to trust him
and to support him and to be
a team like be a team player you know
and unfortunately because people have
been through things because the cultural
narrative is brother's age yeah
and brother's always doing this and
brothers are wacklers and brothers a
wasteman and all of this type of thing
that is part of the cultural narrative
for us as muslims now
even though
we don't have any data to say that
that's the majority we have no way of
knowing whether the majority of muslim
men are simply hard-working average guys
doing the best they can with what they
have we've got no way of knowing whether
that's true or not
but we can assume
that the worst stories are the ones that
everyone knows that the worst narratives
are the ones that keep getting passed
around right and we can assume that the
people who are doing really well tend
not to talk about it yes or no for you
know some valid reasons people don't be
out here showing off about my husband
you know he's such a great provider
masha'allah like i feel so safe and
secure with him and you know
you're not seeing that those sisters who
are happily married by and large they
don't say anything
the sisters who have bad bad experiences
they are the ones who are vocal right so
that means that even culturally amongst
muslims our picture of muslim marriages
is a negative picture because it's
dominated by a particular narrative and
again we don't have data to say whether
that is
a fair portrayal or not
um
subhanallah there's so much more i want
to talk about like
and you know the youth men and
you know modesty and all this but i say
we save it for next time
so i gotta say bro this this has been
the conversation that i did not know i
needed
and subhanallah it's crazy isn't it i
like we talk to people
and you know what they're saying 100
might not be what we need but allah like
speaks through them uses them as like a
tool and he's like all right you're
going to say this specifically at this
point
in this day at this time and this little
thing right here is going to reach this
person that's going to create the
tipping point for them and cause them to
change this system that is crazed
you know brother if i can just say
something inshallah before we wrap up
and this is you know a message to
anybody who hears this conversation and
feels triggered or feels
some kind of way about what i've said
the reality is brother sister
you can do whatever you want
fact
it's a free country is a free world you
can do whatever you want and you can
make any choice you please at the end of
the day
your only answer to allah but understand
that the world has rules and every
choice has a consequence everything that
you decide to do there is a price to pay
so my main thing is get really clear on
the things that you're choosing and the
price that you're paying for those
things and if you can say with your full
chest before allah
this is my choice
no one's here to shame to blame to guilt
you into anything to do like you know
emotional manipulation i don't i don't
believe in that because everybody must
must live an authentic life and a
sincere life
but just understand that the choices you
make have consequences and you will
never be able to escape those
consequences so just get clear on that
you know and if you say for example like
we're saying if you say that you want to
be a wife like just get real with it do
i really want to be a wife though and if
you don't it's for delhi but then we
don't want to see
tick-tocks
of you crying like we're seeing with
these crazy women at the moment i don't
understand
what is up with all of these late 30s
40s women making tick tocks crying about
how they can't find a man and how
there's no man and these men ain't this
and these men ain't that why are you
making tick tocks why why are you doing
this like it's it's this cultural
phenomenon of people over sharing on
social media every single aspect of
their lives and if you
want to end up like that
the footsteps are clear
the road map is there it's our daddy go
ahead
but i don't think most of us want to end
up like that i think most of us hope
that we can get away with as much as we
can get away with and hope that we can
have it all
and what i want to say as somebody who
alhamdulillah has been in this ummah for
a lot you know fairly long time i've
seen a lot
and
i think that we were lied to
i think we were allowed to i think women
in this world were lied to when they
were told you can have it all
there's no such thing there's always a
price to pay and there's always going to
be something has to give
so if you want the career and you want a
phd and you want to be a boss babe and
you want to have all of those things
it's your choice it's your life but just
be aware that there are women who came
before you who were told the same thing
and you can find them on tick tock
crying
about the fact that it's not true
and they thought that at 35 and 38 they
would find a nice 38 year old man a 40
man
40 year old man to marry them and have a
family and all of that kind of thing
because they still wanted that and then
they find that oh there's no men because
all the men married earlier or they
married younger than them and they can
still do that i don't want our sisters
to
to get fooled like they got fooled i
want us to to be smarter than that so
that we don't end up giving up something
that maybe was actually really important
to you because you thought you could
have it all that's all i'm saying
and ramyanho
if you two brothers have anything to say
but let me know now oh oh no you want to
go first one
said everything though
it's been real though honestly i gotta i
gotta admit
i look forward to having you here
inshallah
there's so much to be said on it but i i
still do think the root cause of
everything is is western mentality
western propaganda it's the same reason
why most people in the west most people
look at islam as a negative thing
it's it's it's because that's what's
being propagated and as people who live
here it's being propagated towards us
and if you think you're not susceptible
you're not going to believe it
well i mean
look around you you know you live the
same life as everybody else
and if you're not someone who's actively
learning your deen then you're not
someone who's actively straying away
from the you know anything that opposes
it so subhanallah
problem with modernity with with
presentism with being in the present in
the present place there's a reason and
this is the same thing presentism is
what caused you know westerners to go to
afghanistan iraq and the middle east and
destroy them they're not like us they
don't have what we have they don't have
democracy we need to give them
and this this is what caused the the
division in our ummah to begin with now
we can't allow this to continue the
divide we can't allow this mentality to
to continue the dichotomy the division
between us as muslims as men and women
and what we do as individuals and
something i want to agree with sister um
on
is that marriage
doesn't start with finding the right
person it doesn't marriage starts with
being the best version of yourself and
what did the prophet ali
say
he said
um that you know a man would get married
or a woman get married for wealth status
beauty and wealth or wealth status
beauty lineage so on and so forth things
like that
but if you want to be successful marry
for the dean right in the process he
said that when you when you marry look
for good character and good deen so
although these are things we should
prioritize right and these are things we
should prioritize 100 percent
it doesn't it the process he still
recognized everything else yeah wealth
study
all of that they matter
and although there's an objective there
is some kind of objective standard that
doesn't mean personal preferences you
know don't have anything to do with it
um
so i mean a lot could be said in this
panel i want to leave it there
that's been a very very good discussion
we look forward to having you again soon
yeah i just want to give a quick
reminder guys and girls that is
something that we should strive for in
everything we do
um the solution to corruption from men
it's not black pill and the solution to
this corruption for women it's not
feminism it's islam
when there's no islam you don't do the
opposite of noah's son you you bring in
islam you bringing more song
and sister naima for for anyone that
needs to contact you i don't know if you
do one-on-one sessions or you do any
boot camps like where can they find more
of you
uh i'm on um i'm at naima b robert on
all platforms instagram is my favorite
uh and i am putting together a podcast
with some amazing guests literally about
love and marriage and discussing all of
these things inshallah for my youtube so
i hope to be able to invite you guys to
that very soon
inshallah all right guys links for all
of those in the description which i'll
get with their own whatsapp later all
right rami do your thing
all right with that being salary
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by the value of a dollar goes
lower and lower and lower and the reason
being is because they're printing more
money right that's why money is haram at
least the paper money is haram provided
that you're actually there and you're
being a good father and the mother's
being a good mother best conditions and
behind the mic hamza andreas zorces we
will go in with our final three with
brother
angel in sha
it's not allah a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]